le plus précieux dans la vie ça restera
toujours les gens qui sont là
aujourd'hui
y a que ça qui compte allô allô quête
appareils tu me connais pas mais qui
affichait les deux souvenez de bonnes
choses c'est son grand frère un actuaire
des forces spéciales
ils ont fait un monstre
chez où vit dans un monde qui ne marche
pas selon vos rêves et que ça te plaise
ou non
toi et tes amis en fait partie
maintenant
cette femme est elle dit
c'est ma famille ce coup ci il s'agira
pas seulement d'être rapide
[Musique]
quelqu'un pourrait m'expliquer ce qu'on
ferait exactement
[Musique]
on est au delà de la folie là c'est
carrément cinglé je suis pas en train de
mater
[Musique]